[Background voices]
IRENE KHAN >> This year the sheen of success
has worn off and people are talking about
crisis. Um-yet a lot of the people who are
here were part of the group that created the
crisis so I think it needs to be a much broader
debate on the issues that are here. Ah-the
issues are very important. How do we bring
prosperity back but also how do we ensure
that growth is actually shared more evenly-um-because
this crisis-this economic crisis is going
to hit the poorest and the most vulnerable
in society in the worst possible ways.
Um-so what do the richer half come to tell
us-the political leaders, the business leaders-how
do they make sure that those who are on the
fringes of society-the ones who have been
excluded-are actually brought into the debate?
Because unless that is done, social cohesion
will be threatened. Instability and insecurity
will be-become more prominent issues in this
year. And that has to be taken into account.
Davos is not only about stability and growth.
Davos says, well, this is an economic forum.
It talks about creating a post-crisis, but
we're still in crisis.
We need a much broader debate with all state
colors, and many of them are not here.